The following is a meditation for the first
fundamental motivation of existential analysis, helping us answer
the question of can I be with an
affirmative yes.
The speaker and creator is Graham Nelson Sutter.
Please take a moment to find a seated
position where there's support for the back and
an ability to place your feet flat on
the ground.
It may also be helpful to have a
posture where your back is fairly vertical and
there's little strain on your neck, perhaps where
your head is centered above your spinal column.
If this isn't possible, the variation includes back
support where there are pillows that can support
the weight of your neck.
The goal here is to not sit with
any strain and to find some ease in
your posture.
In addition to your feet being planted flat
on the floor, I invite you to place
your hands on your lap.
If it's possible to close your eyes today,
I invite you to do that as well.
If for any reason it doesn't feel safe
to keep your eyes closed, go ahead and
open them and find a place where you
can rest your gaze, somewhere where there isn't
any activity or distraction.
Let's start by connecting with the experience of
our feet on the ground, noticing how it
is for the bottoms of our feet to
be in contact with the floor.
Perhaps we're wearing socks or shoes or slippers.
Maybe there's a carpet between our feet and
the floor.
Just taking a moment to notice these layers
and textures and materials between our feet to
the floor.
Perhaps there's a feeling of softness and firmness
and also noticing the flatness and stability of
the floor.
The stillness of the floor.
See if it's possible to place your attention
under your toes, noticing what is it like
for my toes to be connected with the
floor?
Shifting to the pads of your feet, noticing
the contact there and the arches of your
feet and also your heels.
Be noticing the difference in pressure between your
toes and the floor and your heels on
the floor, seeing if you can draw your
attention to your ankles, up to your calf
muscles.
Perhaps this is a point where there's contact
with your chair or couch.
If that's present, just noticing that contact beginning
and then shifting towards the back of your
knees, around the hinge of your knees, starting
with your hamstrings.
As you travel down your hamstrings, noticing the
contact with your chair or couch.
Perhaps there's a shift or a change in
pressure as you move your focus from the
back of your knees down your hamstrings towards
your glutes, noticing the difference in pressure below
your torso versus your thighs.
Perhaps here you can perceive that the couch
or chair that you're on also has this
mix of soft and firmness.
Next, see if it's possible to shift your
awareness to your lower back, noticing where your
hips and back connect and where the support
from your chair starts to come from behind.
Becoming aware of the shift of support from
below and under to this new form of
support from behind.
Gently traveling up to your mid-back, following
your spinal column, moving up towards your shoulders,
your shoulder blades, noticing the sensations of support
for your back from behind, and
seeing if it's possible to shift your awareness
to your neck.
Perhaps there's support here, contact or not.
If your head is vertically above your spine,
just noticing how your head is resting on
your neck and shoulders.
And if you have pillows supporting your neck
and head, just noticing that form of support
as well.
And be asking yourself the question, is it
possible to receive even more of this support
at this time?
Next, see if it's possible to shift your
awareness towards your breathing without the need to
change how you're breathing.
When you inhale, perhaps you experience some coolness
around your nostrils or lips.
And when you exhale, perhaps there's some warmth
around your nostrils and lips.
When you inhale, maybe you can feel the
sensation in your chest, the sensation of expansion
and opening.
And when you exhale, perhaps you can feel
the sensation of rest and release.
Noticing that with every breath, the space within
you becomes present.
Next, I invite you to notice your skin.
Taking a moment to become aware of the
places where your skin is exposed to the
air.
Perhaps this is your hands or wrists or
arms or neck and your face.
Just noticing these areas of the body that
are in direct contact with the air.
Taking a moment to experience what it's like
to touch the air to your skin.
Maybe you feel coolness or warmth from the
air around you.
Perhaps you notice stillness or movement of air.
Taking a moment also to notice your skin.
That your skin seems to have two sides
of it on one side is the part
that connects with the outside world.
And the other part holding you and your
body.
Maybe noticing the flexibility of the skin.
And see now if you can expand your
awareness to your clothing.
Noticing the parts of the body that have
clothing.
Perhaps you have the sensation of different fabrics
and textures.
Maybe even light pressure.
Perhaps there's a difference in temperature.
Noticing as well that your clothing is like
a second skin.
It too has this inside and outside quality.
On the outside is the world around you.
And on the inside of your clothes is
you.
Wherever you go today your clothing is there
with you.
And so is your skin.
Both working together to provide this flexible boundary
of protection wherever you go.
Perhaps noticing that your skin and your clothing
don't really require your active involvement.
They're just there.
They're all connected to part of you.
There's nothing here for you to do.
This natural and flexible boundary is here and
does not require your intervention.
It just is.
It will follow you where you go.
You can just be with it.
And the same is true of your breathing
and breath.
Whether you focus on your breath or not,
your body will continue to breathe for you.
You've been breathing this time and you will
continue to breathe.
The same is true of the support that
is here for you.
This couch, this chair, this floor.
They're here.
They don't require you to do anything to
receive their support.
You're invited to shift your awareness from having
to do something to instead be at
this moment and this time.
The support is here at this moment and
this time.
There's space in your chest to breathe.
And at this moment and this time your
skin and your clothing provide this natural flexible
boundary to protect you and your body.
When it feels appropriate, taking your time, I
invite you to gently open your eyes and
return to this shared space.